[Music]  start by chopping chicken thighs into  pieces now on with the marinade chopped  garlic ginger red chili  and lemon juice in a pan toast coriander  and cumin seeds to release their flavors  grind and add to the chicken  then pour over plain yogurt add turmeric  and season mix and lead to marinate from  2 hours to overnight next fry chopped  onions in olive oil then add chopped  garlic and ginger ground coriander  gamrath ala and turmeric tomato puree  and butter  next add the marinated chicken and all  the remaining marinade and cook until  tender finally top with coriander  marinated for flavor and cooked in 20  minutes  chili chicken with ginger and coriander  a simple stress-free wander  rub thoroughly with the jug mix and  marinade  [Applause]  but there's hitting the bottom of the  pan without some out of puree  we call it cooking out with smart puree